et c'est parti pour ce club des
territoires on va parler de tourisme
aujourd'hui et nous sommes avec Florent
maillet bonjour vous êtes rédacteur en
chef adjoint pour la version numérique
du Figaro voyage nous sommes également
avec Linda Lainé rédactrice en chef au
magazine l'Echo touristique bonjour on
va parler tourisme et plus précisément
du sur tourisme c'est-à-dire de la
saturation de certains lieux
touristiques de certains sites naturels
qui du coup sont mises en danger et les
îlots locaux sont obligés de prendre des
mesures pour réguler cette fréquentation
touristique mais d'abord on va voir
l'actualité dans nos régions et plus
précisément en Alsace ont été Emmanuel
Macron hier
[Musique]
et pour parler de cette visite
mouvementée du président de la
République hier en Alsace on va
retrouver nos partenaires du journal
L'Alsace avec Laurent Bodin journaliste
et éditorialiste au journal L'Alsace
bonjour Laurent
alors aujourd'hui à lire dans vos pages
et bien il y a cette interview exclusive
pour les journaux du groupe Ebra
interview d'Emmanuel Macron qui a été en
déplacement dans votre département hier
oui en fait c'est à la fois un bilan et
une projection Emmanuel Macron ironique
il mesure les colères il y aura selon
lui des manifestations et des concerts
de casseroles même ma responsabilité
n'est pas de dire je vous ai entendu je
ne vais rien faire Emmanuel Macron veut
aller au contact il estime qu'il doit
expliquer et corriger il précise que
c'est pour cela que le texte sera
complété le texte sur les retraites sera
complété avec le pacte de la vie au
travail je ne méprise personne et je dis
toujours la vérité aux Français assure
le président de la République qui ajoute
ceux qui sont méprisants sont ceux qui
ne disent pas la vérité le président de
la République rend aussi hommage aux
partenaires sociaux qui selon lui
au-delà des désaccords sur les retraites
n'ont jamais arrêté de travailler je
laisserai passer le 1er mai comme les
syndicats l'ont demandé et je les
réinviterai courant mais ma porte est
ouverte réponds le président de la
République qui prend un engagement de
méthode ce qui sera bâti entre syndicats
et patronat sera retransmis retranscrit
fidèlement c'est sans limite et sans
tabou enfin le président de la
République note que nos concitations
vont de moins en moins voter mais
veulent participer de plus en plus aux
décisions selon lui beaucoup d'élus de
Terra le savent ils organisent des
référendums locaux sans qu'il y ait
beaucoup de participation et Emmanuel
Macron de dénoncer le comportement à
l'Assemblée nationale de la France
insoumise et du rassemblement national
dont l'histoire politique et non
républicaine selon lui toute la journée
en stéréo la France insoumise et le
rassemblement national répète que les
institutions ne sont pas légitimes c'est
dangereux selon président la République
pour qui on ne peut pas avoir dans un
pays démocratique un procès en
légitimité quand les gens élus
respectent le cadre légal car selon lui
sinon c'est la pyramide de la rue et du
désordre et puis Laurent vous signez
aujourd'hui dans les colonnes de
l'Alsace en éditorial intitulé dans un
climat électrique une détestation
grandissante
oui en effet c'est moins le nombre de
participants de manifestations c'est
moins le nombre de manifestants somme
toute que la détermination de ces gens
ordinaires spécialement venus crier leur
mécontentement au chef de l'État en
Alsace qui interroge un inquiétant
climat climat haineux nourri par la
détestation grandissante de la personne
du présent la République est en train de
s'installer durablement c'est la
fonction présidentielle est abîmée et ce
n'est évidemment pas bon pour le pays
alors évidemment Emmanuel Macron n'est
pas étranger à cette ambiance il en est
même à l'origine à travers un exercice
du pouvoir toujours aussi vertical mais
les insultes et les injures à l'instar
de cette accusation de gouvernement
corrompu lancé à la phase du président
de la République hier en Alsace ont
tourné en boucle pour alimenter
finalement la chaîne de désinformation
concurrent aussi à saper les fondements
démocratiques malsain ce climat
politique haineux est entretenu par des
oppositions la France insoumise souffle
effectivement sur les braises tentant
d'entretenir une ambiance
insurrectionnelle à travers un procès
permanent légitimité dont au final seul
Marine Le Pen récolte aujourd'hui les
fruits Emmanuel Macron c'est ce constat
qu'il fait dans l'interview qu'il a
accordé aux journaux du groupe E et
qu'on peut retrouver dans nos éditions
papiers de l'Alsace mais aussi sur notre
site internet l'alsace.fr merci beaucoup
Laurent et justement on va revoir la Une
du journal L'Alsace aujourd'hui
consacrée à cette visière d'Emmanuel
Macron dans ce département sous les hués
des manifestants avec cette interview à
lire d'Emmanuel Macron dans les colonnes
de tous les journaux du groupe prébra
des journaux de l'Est de la France merci
beaucoup Laurent on va ouvrir le thème
de ce club des territoires aujourd'hui
on va parler du tourisme et de la notion
de surtoutisme de plus en plus de lieux
touristiques en France son prix d'assaut
par les touristes avec et bien une mise
en danger de certains sites naturels
c'est le cas par exemple des plages et
des falaises d'Etretat en Normandie
regardez ce reportage de Marion Vigreux
c'est un site majestueux la plage
d'Étretat c'est falaises de Crêts
blanches qui domine la Manche et son
arche de pierre des paysages mythiques
de la Haute-Normandie tellement mythique
que l'année dernière encore 1,5 millions
de visiteurs les ont arpentés en cause
le boom du tourisme local poste covid le
succès de la série Arsène Lupin ou
encore les milliers de publications sur
les réseaux sociaux une aubaine pour
l'économie locale un désastre pour
l'environnement déjà fragilisés par le
recul du trait de côte shaymala est une
enfant du pays elle vit à Étretat et se
bat aujourd'hui contre ce phénomène du
surturisme qui a ses yeux endommage le
milieu naturel une des conséquences du
sur tourisme c'est la disparition des
galets
les galets ils sont là pour pour
protéger notre village de la submersion
ou des innovations des tempêtes les gens
ont tendance à prendre ces galettes pour
juste le les exposer chez eux ou parfois
même les revendre alors que c'est
interdit les revendes sur Internet les
jours plein la fréquentation peut
atteindre les 10000 visiteurs alors pour
préserver le site quelques aménagements
ont eu lieu fini le parking en haut des
falaises il faut monter à pied et suivre
un sentier unique pour sécuriser les
lieux et éviter les piétinements
incessants qui ont fait disparaître
l'herbe mais pour les associations
locales il faut aller plus loin d'un
point de vue de préservation de
l'environnement et c'est pas suffisant
je bah les âges il faudrait instaurer
une jauge de fréquentation peut-être par
exemple on pourrait considérer
qu'au-delà de 5000 personnes le village
ne serait plus accessible si on le
préserve pas maintenant je pense qu'il y
aura une interdiction à l'avenir si la
falaise disparaît parce qu'on l'a trop
on la trop piétiné mais là personne
pourra en profiter et ça ce serait
vraiment dommage autre problématique ce
village de 1200 habitants n'est pas
adapté à une telle fréquentation pas
assez de commerce pas assez de parking
et une ville locale qui se dégrade pour
les habitants
Marie Océane et son mari gère l'école de
voile de la commune arrivé il y a deux
ans ils ont eu beaucoup de mal à trouver
une maison à acheter tous les biens qui
étaient dans notre dans notre type de
recherche
partez extrêmement rapidement et
notamment on a eu plusieurs fois le cas
où on avait des rendez-vous pour des
visites et où le bien était acheté par
téléphone le jour même donc on avait
même pas la possibilité de le visiter
étant donné que il partait et c'était
systématiquement pour de l'investisseur
qui venait pour en faire du Airbnb mais
pour les élus locaux pas question de
mettre être ta sous cloche eux veulent
miser sur une meilleure répartition des
touristes sur l'ensemble de l'année et
surtout le territoire de la Côte
d'Albâtre que les locaux évitent
certains weekends qui sont extrêmement
surchargés vont faire des parkings en
déconcentré des parkings un peu plus
loin c'est le cas de
Saint-Guilhem-le-Désert c'est le cas du
Mont-Saint-Michel soyez bien qu'ici on
peut pas fermer le village Étretat des
entrées sont multiples donc il faut ça
passe par de la pédagogie tous les ans
on a un camion site info qui tourne sur
toutes les communes qui vient donner des
bonnes pratiques depuis cette année être
ta fait partie du label grand site qui
doit garantir un tourisme de qualité et
ce alors que dans le même temps le site
de voyage américain phodor a placé les
falaises sur la liste des 10
destinations mondiales à mettre sur
pause car victimes du tourisme de masse
et voilà pour ce reportage de Marion
Vigreux à Étretat Florent maillet cette
situation de la commune d'Etretat ça
illustre bien ce phénomène de
surtourisme est-ce que c'est un
phénomène nouveau qui se développe ces
dernières années non c'est pas un
phénomène nouveau je pense qu'il offre
un parfait résumé des excès et de ce que
peut représenter le sur tourisme si on
essaye de définir le sur tourisme je
pense qu'on peut parler d'une croissance
excessive d'un nombre de visiteurs et
qui a des effets néfastes sur les
populations locales ou sur
l'environnement je pense qu'on est tout
à fait dans ce cas de figure sur Étretat
c'est pas nouveau néanmoins depuis le
covid il y a un effet démultiplicateur
et il y a aussi une plus grosse focale
de la part des médias des populations
locales parce que ça entraîne des effets
à répétition notamment les crises des
logements donc là on est vraiment dans
les effets néfastes pour les populations
locales et également on en parlait
Étretat vous rappeler de l'histoire des
galets des conséquences pour
l'environnement avec un trait de côte
qui recule et accentuer par notamment
les touristes qui repartent avec des
souvenirs donc on est vraiment dans un
parfait exemple du sur tourisme on va
évoquer les différents impacts de ce sur
tourisme à Linda Lee ce n'est pas un
phénomène nouveau mais on peut dire
qu'il est vraiment en développement dans
les années post covid effectivement pas
un phénomène nouveau et surtout risque
le thème même de sur tourisme existait
avant la crise sanitaire et les raisons
sont très simples si on regarde une
trajectoire longue j'aime bien rappeler
les chiffres que donne le sociologue
Jean Viard en 1968 il y avait 60
millions de visiteurs du touristes
internationaux en 2019 on était à 1
milliard 5 donc il y a une croissance
assez régulière de du tourisme hormis
les années coïdes ça c'est le premier
point ensuite il y a un effet de
concentration c'est à dire qu'on a pour
coutume de dire que
95% environ des touristes vont sur 5%
des territoires donc malheureusement le
site d'Étretat en est l'exemple type
et en plus le reportage le montrait bien
il y a aussi un phénomène de
concentration sur la haute saison
juillet août les ponts du mois de mai
qui vont qui vont arriver donc il
faudrait dans le meilleur des cas
parvenir à une meilleure dispersion des
flux touristiques comme d'ailleurs le
propose et le répète à notre sociologue
j'en disais urbain il faut arriver
effectivement à déconcentrer de manière
à ce qui est beaucoup moins de pression
et sur l'environnement et sur les
populations locales qui elles vivent au
quotidien parfois les les désagréments
du tourisme même si il y a aussi des
bienfaits il faut il est bon de rappeler
quand même que au niveau mondial un
emploi sur 10 et de l'industrie du
tourisme donc le tourisme reste une
industrie porteuse en termes économique
et en termes d'emploi ça reste un
secteur qui fait vivre différents
territoires Florent maillet ce sur
tourisme il est aussi et bien intensifié
par les réseaux sociaux il suffit d'une
photo sur Instagram de la part d'un
influenceur connu et ça y est il y a une
concentration de touristes exactement et
puis on en revient je rebondis sur ce
chiffre effectivement qui peut paraître
impressionnant mais qui à mon avis
correspond quand même à la réalité c'est
vraiment 95% des ces flux touristes on
parle de 1,5 milliards de touristes au
niveau mondial qui se concentre sur les
5 % qui sont en priorité des zones
littorales mais également en ce moment
vous avez la floraison des cerisiers au
Japon voilà c'est quelque chose de très
populaire aussi vous avez le Mont Blanc
en France qui a un des totems voilà donc
il y a quelques totems comme ça et qui
dont la fréquentation est accentuée par
les réseaux sociaux pas seulement mais
effectivement le phénomène puisqu'on
prenait l'exemple d'Étretat
rappelez-vous il y a des morts à être
tas des gens qui s'approchent de la
falaise pour prendre des selfies voilà
c'est une démonstration dramatique et
par l'absurde de ce phénomène des
réseaux sociaux qui enjolivent
effectivement le surtourisme avec oui
on va aussi assister à une à une
transformation des messages c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est beaucoup dans la
promotion de sites touristiques mais
avec le temps on va être de plus en plus
dans la pédagogie les calanques en soi
un exemple c'est-à-dire qu'on le
les gens qui font la promotion des
Calanques vont pouvoir expliquer que il
faut éviter de venir au coeur de l'été
que il faut préserver sinon on ne pourra
pas venir sur place à compter du mois de
juin la réservation sera obligatoire à
ce Giton et c'est quelque part une bonne
nouvelle parce que cela permettra
d'améliorer aussi l'expérience sur place
donc il faut le voir également comme un
outil pédagogique donc les réseaux
sociaux Instagram en premier peut petit
à petit devenir un outil au service à la
fois des territoires mais également d'un
voyageur plus responsable enjeu
logique car il y a un véritable péril
environnement environnemental sur
certains sites naturels qui sont saturés
de touristes Florent maillet oui tout à
fait et puis on parle de site contrats
sur un plan géographique on l'a rappelé
c'était rappelé dans votre reportage
être là vous pouvez pas fermer un
village quand vous êtes sur le Mont
Blanc vous pouvez pas fermer tous les
accès au Mont Blanc c'est le grand
paradoxe c'est que ces fameux 5% de la
surface du monde si demain on en venait
à les il y a une forme de régulation à
trouver je pense que ça tout le monde
est à peu près d'accord là-dessus le
problème c'est qu'à partir du moment où
vous régulez ces espaces là les gens
peuvent être tentés d'aller vers
d'autres espaces si vous fermez ces
calanques de Sugiton les gens
visiblement envie de voir des Calanques
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire ils vont
soit trouver des alternatives soit aller
dans d'autres lieux qui ne sont pas
forcément prévus pour les accueillir
donc effectivement il y a tout un
travail de pédagogie la pédagogie
peut-être qu'elle doit aller jusqu'à
indiquer à ces gens quels sont entre
guillemets les plans B et on va voir les
mesures qui sont
par les élus sur ces sites pour essayer
de réguler ce sur tourisme quel site en
France Audrey prennent ce type de
mesures alors je vous en ai faire un
petit tour de France car vous l'avez dit
la problématique du sur tourisme touche
de nombreux sites sur notre territoire
du Mont-Saint-Michel au Mont-Blanc en
passant par les calanques à Marseille ou
alors les Bouches de Bonifacio en Corse
à chaque site sa tentative de solution
QR code justement dans les calanques de
Marseille comme au musée il faut avoir
fait sa réservation à l'avance pour
certaines calanques écouter
l'accès à cette calanque est désormais
soumis à permis du site à une
réservation avec effectivement des
points de filtrage aux deux entrées de
la calanque donc ici celle de la piste
de Luminy et de l'autre côté celle du
sentier venant de Morgiou
il en va de même aussi pour le Mont
Blanc pour l'ascension si on veut monter
jusqu'en haut il faut avoir fait une
réservation dans l'un des refuges le
bivouac est interdit parce que après il
y a des problèmes aussi de danger mortel
quand on fait une ascension et qui a
trop de monde sur ces sur ces pistes
d'ascension et Audrey est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres méthodes qui sont utilisées
pour protéger ces sites exceptionnels
comme dans la réserve naturelle des
Bouches de Bonifacio et pour cause dans
les années 70 il y avait 400 visiteurs
par an aujourd'hui tenez vous bien
presque 300 000 visiteurs chaque année
dans un site qui est pourtant
extrêmement fragile alors l'Assemblée de
Corse a fixé quota la fréquentation est
limitée à 2000 personnes par jour en
fait c'est assez simple à mettre en
place parce qu'il faut y accéder par
bateau sachez aussi que certains sites
pratiquent le démarketing qui consiste à
réduire la communication sur les sites
trop fréquentés vous en avez parlé c'est
pas vraiment ce que peut faire le Mont
Saint-Michel qui est vraiment très connu
si connu que son abbaye est le deuxième
monument le plus visité de France après
l'Arc de Triomphe 1,3 millions d'entrée
en 2022 alors la solution qui va être
choisie c'est d'afficher la
fréquentation du site en temps réel sur
le site internet pour informer les
visiteurs quand un seuil important est
dépassé et pour essayer d'étaler en fait
la fréquentation sur le site merci
beaucoup Audrey on le voit il y a toute
une palette de solutions qui sont
utilisés pour essayer de contrer ce
phénomène de surtourisme et notamment
tout simplement la réservation pour
aller sur un site touristique exactement
aujourd'hui c'est un levier de plus en
plus utilisé plus facile à mettre en
place pour sur les sites culturels je
vais prendre un exemple en France c'est
le Louvre le Louvre l'été dernier a mis
en place un système de réservation tout
simplement pour améliorer l'expérience
du visiteur et finalement ça le principe
a bien fonctionné on était à 30 000
visiteurs par jour et finalement ça
permet en arrivant sur place de
d'attendre très peu de temps tout
simplement le temps de la validation de
la pré-rés réservation et finalement on
voit bien que le digital lui aussi va
permettre justement de d'embarquer les
sites touristiques culturels dans cette
démarche de de d'aménagement également
des visites dans le temps pour pour
éviter qu'on soit tous au même moment de
voilà je compte et donc
il est fortement probable que que ce
principe perdure dans le temps et là
aussi c'est nécessaire parce qu'au
moment de l'ouverture du Grand Louvre
donc en 1989 le site avait été prévu
pour 4 millions de visiteurs par an et
là tenez-vous bien avant la crise du
covid on était déjà à 10 millions de
visiteurs donc on voit bien que parce
qu'il y a une croissance donc des flux
touristiques une croissance
démographique les sites culturels vont
devoir petit à petit aménager leur leurs
entrées avec des Sud digitaux
ce n'est pas totalement nouveau depuis
maintenant très longtemps des sites qui
sont très fréquentés ont déjà adopté ce
type de solutions je pense à l'Alhambra
par exemple en Espagne ça fait très
longtemps que si vous n'avez pas réservé
si vous n'avez pas anticipé
malheureusement vous risquez de passer à
côté de ce petit joyau c'est inévitable
on va mettre de plus en plus en place ce
système de réservation pour les lieux
touristiques et pour les sites naturels
ça semble effectivement inévitable c'est
la démonstration qu'en réalité on agit
sur la valve c'est-à-dire que finalement
on acte le fait qu'on vit aujourd'hui
dans une société de loisirs les gens
partent les gens ont envie de partir
partir voyager est associé à une forme
de bien-être alors on dit voilà sur
certaines périodes de vacances qui ont
tendance d'ailleurs à croître on est sur
une année de pont donc beaucoup de gens
vont ont l'intention de partir
restreignent les achats alimentaires
pour dédier cette partie là aux achats
de loisirs donc les gens partent et sur
ce volume de gens qui parlent
effectivement vous allez partir mais pas
comme avant il va falloir vous organiser
il va falloir réserver avant il va
falloir organiser votre voyage de
manière différente ce qui est une
approche complètement contradictoire
avec l'esprit premier qui était
finalement dire partez posez vous
quelque part et puis organiser vos
activités voilà aujourd'hui ça devient
beaucoup plus difficile de s'organiser
de la sorte pour une visite au musée
pour parfois une réservation au
restaurant je pense qu'on a tous vécu
aujourd'hui il faut s'y prendre beaucoup
plus tôt donc c'est une manière qui est
complètement différente d'envisager son
voyage beaucoup plus encadré et avec
visiblement beaucoup moins de liberté
donc ça change les pratiques
touristiques qui a une autre solution
qui est utilisée face à ces saturation
de certains sites touristiques c'est ce
qu'on appelle le démarketing et des élus
qui finalement font la promotion pour ne
pas venir sur les sites touristiques de
leur territoire et vous croyez cette
solution lindalene alors je pense que
c'est une solution pour finalement
parvenir à une
cohabitation harmonieuse entre les
touristes et locaux on voit bien que
depuis quelques mois quelques années il
y a une tension croissante entre ces
deux populations alors qu'elles sont
tout intérêts à s'entendre au quotidien
donc le démarketing ça peut être
justement une façon d'éviter comme on
disait dans le reportage que demain
certains sites soient totalement
inaccessibles parce qu'on sera arrivé à
un point de rupture il y a un exemple à
l'étranger en Thaïlande à vous souvenez
sans doute de ce fameux film la plage
donc c'est à Maya Bay et donc le site a
été victime de son succès et ils ont dû
fermer pendant quatre ans c'est
un concevable donc tout ça pour que
justement la nature reprenne un peu ses
droits et cela a fonctionné les coraux
se sont reconstituées et maintenant d'un
système de jauge c'est très encadré et
voilà donc il faut arriver effectivement
parfois les solutions de démarchesing
pour éviter les points de rupture d'un
autre exemple en Espagne et un village
qui a refusé en Catalogne de devenir
plus beau village d'Espagne parce qu'il
y a 30 ans de personnes qui ont mis sur
place et sont dit en fait si jamais on a
cette exposition médiatique on va en
pâtir au niveau de notre quotidien donc
c'est absolument nécessaire de parfois
envoyer des messages qui peuvent
paraître contradictoires mais qui sont
pour le bien-être de tout le monde allez
on va aller sur le massif du Mont Blanc
puisqu'on est en duplex avec Jean-Marc
Peillex le maire de la commune de
Saint-Gervais-les-Bains bonjour
Jean-Marc Peillex alors à l'automne
dernier vous avez lancé un appel à
Emmanuel Macron pour justement endiguer
ce phénomène de sur tourisme sur votre
territoire est-ce que vous avez eu des
réponses
alors oui il y a des réponses puisque le
président de la République a confié ce
dossier à ces ministres et à ses
conseillers je pense qu'il est
effectivement temps que l'État reprenne
la main et fixe les règles c'est-à-dire
que l'État disent une chose qui est très
simple
il y a des sites qui sont sur fréquentés
comme vous l'avez dit il y a des
activités dans les sites naturels qui
sont maintenant devenus complètement
démesurées et
il est la limite et que l'état donne
de ton ensuite il faut que sur que sur
les territoires le préfet et les élus
locaux et bien implique cette
philosophie pour éviter justement qu'on
arrive à des dérives telles que vous les
avez décrites et aujourd'hui c'est le
vrai souci c'est d'agir avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard
et justement sur le site du massif du
Mont-Blanc quelle mesure sont mises en
oeuvre pour éviter la saturation
touristique
vous savez il faut pas croire que la
pédagogie fonctionne encore la pédagogie
c'était avec les anciens touristes les
nouveaux touristes se sont des apports
des consommateurs d'un jour et il s'en
fiche pas mal de l'image qu'il laisse
derrière eux puisqu'il ne reviendront
jamais donc si vous voulez la pédagogie
tout le monde est d'accord mais pour les
autres et certainement pas quand les
gens vont fréquenter ces sites donc il y
a qu'une mesure c'est la régulation
c'est l'encadrement et c'est dire ce que
l'on veut faire de nos sites il faut pas
attendre détruit et que plus personne
puisse en profiter il faut au contraire
qu'on définisse des règles qu'on
définisse parfois des quotas qu'on
définisse des cadres d'utilisation qu'on
puisse lever le pied quand on est dans
la nature parce que la nature est dans
un état de souffrance comme l'année
dernière et qu'on continue pas à faire
des courses de montagne à faire des
choses qui sont qu'ignorent complètement
l'état de l'environnement ou l'état de
la ville donc il est urgent que les élus
prennent leur responsabilité et que il
soit moteur pour éviter justement que
tout nos sites touristiques ne soient
demain dévastés parce que il y aura eu
un effet de mode il y aura eu des gens
qui seront venus parce que les médias
auront vanté tel ou tel site où les
réseaux sociaux mais les médias font
exactement le même travail qui est
négatif c'est à dire qu'en valorisant un
site dans le Figaro ou dans d'autres ou
dans d'autres titres et bien il est
évident que vous avez plein de touristes
qui sélectionnent ce site parce que on
aura parlé de lui parce qu'il faut que
son image personnelle soit associée à
l'image du site et la problématique
d'Instagram du sommet du Mont-Blanc
c'est exactement ça et justement sur le
sommet du Mont-Blanc on comprend bien
votre appel à une régulation des flux
touristiques mais ce qu'il y a des
mesures concrètes qui sont mises en
oeuvre oui alors nous on l'a mis en
oeuvre on a le président de la
République a sauvé le Mont Blanc en 2020
en faisant faire un arrêté de protection
des habitats naturels et aujourd'hui la
fréquentation du Mont Blanc est limitée
à la capacité des refuges mais après
tout on n'a rien inventé puisque vous ne
montez pas dans un avion quand il y a
plus de place ou quand vous n'avez pas
de réservation vous n'allez pas dans une
chambre d'hôtel quand elle est occupée
donc nous n'avons fait au travers de cet
arrêté que
appliquer le bon sens ou plutôt le faire
revenir
alors concrètement comment ça marche
c'est un système de réservation dans les
requins de réservation comme pour un
avion c'est-à-dire que vous réservez
votre place et puis s'il y a pas de
place vous il faut différer votre votre
ascension mais on est dans un milieu
naturel il peut y avoir aussi plein
d'autres choses le mauvais temps et vous
perdrez votre place et vous ne
reviendrez pas le lendemain puisque il
faudra une nouvelle réservation
Florent maillet une réaction justement
sur ce que disait Jean-Marc cayex qui a
dit qu'il y a aussi une responsabilité
des médias à côté des réseaux sociaux
dans la pédagogie attention à ne pas
faire la promotion de certains sites qui
sont saturés
de réaction la première c'est une
réaction je trouve que les élus locaux
semblent un peu livrer à eux-mêmes on
est quand même dans un pays on leur
rappelait tout à l'heure avec des
chiffres très importants concerne le
touriste c'est 8% du PIB français c'est
plus de 2 millions d'emplois indirects
et des sites Saint-Gervais c'est le
deuxième site de montagne de France
après Chamonix avec le plus grand bureau
des guides et un site connu mondialement
pour l'alpinisme donc Chamonix ou
Saint-Gervais attire des alpinistes
c'est pas très étonnant ce qui est
étonnant c'est de se dire que finalement
ces mers sont amenés à prendre des
mesures locales la question c'est mon
deuxième point est-ce que ces gens qui
ne peuvent pas venir ce sera intéressant
de savoir si au 20 avril d'ailleurs il
reste des places dans les refuges je
serais très curieux de connaître votre
réponse est-ce que ces gens qui ne
peuvent pas venir au Mont Blanc ne
devons pas se déporter vers d'autres
sites est-ce que vos voisins de la
Vanoise ou des Écrins pardon ne vont pas
prendre ces vagues de visiteurs est-ce
qu'il va pas y avoir des conséquences
sur vos collègues d'autres territoires
adjacents
alors je vais répondre simplement non
parce qu'en fait les gens cherchent à
briller vous avez eu deux youtubeurs qui
ont voulu mettre une tente sur le Mont
Blanc au mois d'octobre dernier pour
pour faire
sur les réseaux sociaux un buzz mais il
s'en fiche pas mal ils vont pas aller
sur un sommet de Valois et de Vanoise ou
à Saint-Gervais sur le Mont-Joli ils
vont aller sur le Mont Blanc parce qu'il
n'y a plus que le Mont Blanc c'est à
dire que notre société touristique
aujourd'hui elle se résume à des spots
on ne va plus découvrir un pays on va
découvrir ces pépites et ça c'est vrai
que l'ensemble de ceux qui font de la
communication
est responsable que ce soit les médias
que ce soit les politiques de de
marketing ou de communication des
collectivités que ce soit les réseaux
sociaux on est responsable tous c'est
que ces collectif personne ne doit être
montré du doigt mais c'est vrai que les
gens aujourd'hui ne font plus rien
d'autre que ce qu'il est fait briller et
ce qui permettra de dire j'étais à tel
endroit parce qu'il est connu mais
d'aller dans un endroit qui n'est pas
connu mais ça n'intéresse plus personne
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup Jean-Marc
peix pour votre intervention je rappelle
que vous êtes maire de la commune de
Saint-Gervais les Bains Linda l'année
une réaction certains éloquaux sont un
peu livrés eux-mêmes justement pour
faire face à cette saturation
touristique par rapport à ce témoignage
très intéressant
effectivement je pense que les médias
ont une responsabilité on aime bien
promouvoir les sites qui qui méritent le
détour voilà après je pense que là aussi
enfin j'ai envie d'avoir une vision
optimiste il peut y avoir une évolution
ainsi cette année le guide phodor phodor
ont publié la liste des 10 sites à
éviter sur le plan du tourisme et parmi
ces sites partout dans le monde il y a
deux en France qui ne vont pas vous
étonner ce sont les calanques et Étretat
alors quel est le message subliminal
c'est de dire ce site sont magnifiques
mais s'il vous plaît parce que justement
ils sont victimes de leur succès
oubliez-les pour le moment essayez de
vous tourner vers d'autres spots qui
sont peut-être moins touristiques mais
qui sont tout aussi jolies donc ça
revient à l'idée qu'on évoquait un peu
plus tôt il faut essayer de diffuser il
y a des villages qui sont prêts à
accueillir
de manière raisonnable des touristes
donc toute une question aussi de
diffusion et donc de mais je comprends
je comprends la colère du maire de
Saint-Gervais c'est très compliqué et ce
n'est pas un cas isolé vous avez
peut-être aussi entendu parler du projet
de Tony Parker l'exta du basket il a il
a décidé de d'acheter une station de ski
alors je crois que c'est assez vilain de
Lens
et donc il a l'intention il a le projet
de construire un complexe touristique
très important de 900 lits et là aussi
le maire visiblement appuie plutôt le
dossier mais là ce sont les habitants
qui disent mais ce projet là aujourd'hui
il est démesuré par rapport justement à
notre à notre village donc il faut
entendre les élus il faut entendre les
habitants il faut effectivement être
plus dans la consultation parce qu'il y
a une question d'acceptabilité sociale
du développement touristique dernier mot
rapidement pour conclure l'enjeu c'est
la pédagogie et l'écoute aussi des
habitants sur place sur ces sites oui le
terme d'acceptabilité me semble tout à
fait correspondre à la réalité
acceptabilité puis j'ai envie de dire
paradoxe parce que quelque part c'est
commune ces mères en vivent ils vivent
des taxes payées les acteurs dont on
parle font vivre les gens et permettent
de maintenir une activité dans les
villages et à ce moment-là il faut
trouver autre chose je pense
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que le tourisme est
important et nécessaire qu'il faut mieux
le réguler mais peut-être mieux le
coordonner au niveau national apporter
des réponses uniformes merci à tous les
deux d'être venu parler de ce phénomène
de surtorisme dans ce club vous restez
avec nous on va voir ce qu'il y a à la
une de nos quotidiens régionaux
[Musique]
une revue de prese des territoires
aujourd'hui avec vous Audrey et à la Une
et bien forcément on parle de la
première visite du chef de l'État poste
réforme des retraites c'est ça fait la
Une de beaucoup de quotidiens et jeunes
oui
les concerts de casseroles alors la
Dépêche du Midi s'interroge peut-on
parler d'un retour impossible pas pour
le chef de l'État qui a affirmé hier à
une manifestante ce n'est pas la
première fois que j'entends des gens qui
râlent après moi j'ai connu bien pire en
marge de son déplacement Emmanuel Macron
a répondu aussi aux questions des
journaux du groupe Ebra une interview
dans laquelle il réaffirme de mépriser
personne toujours dire la vérité aux
Français le président qui veut tout de
même changer de séquence je mesure les
colères mais je dois agir ce sont les
mots retenus par le progrès et puis les
chantiers à venir parmi les chantiers à
venir il y a celui de l'éducation
nouveau déplacement aujourd'hui pour le
président de la République sur ce thème
ce sera à Ganges au nord de Montpellier
nous rapporte Midi Libre qui a déjà
songé quelques habitants plutôt content
de cette visite du chef de l'État qui se
sera donc sur le thème de l'éducation
mais ils ont aussi prévu de lui parler
de la fermeture de la maternité à
proximité du sentiment de déclassement
de la pauvreté vous le comprenez des
échanges qui pourraient être une
nouvelle fois à s'étendue parmi les
dossiers inflammables du moment il y a
aussi les fameuses et des feux les zones
à faibles émission dans les villes oui
c'est le dossier de Sud-Ouest
aujourd'hui il s'agit d'interdire les
véhicules les plus polluants dans les 43
métropoles de plus de 150 000 habitants
celle de Bordeaux en fait partie elle se
plaira à la loi mais sans enthousiasme
parce que parmi les élus personne n'est
d'accord le maire de Bordeaux pierre
urmu qui est pourtant écologiste n'est
pas pour il a le sentiment d'être laissé
à l'abandon par l'État en race campagne
pour défendre une mesure qui est
compliquée à faire entendre parce que
les véhicules les plus polluants se sont
en général des personnes qui les
possèdent qui n'ont pas les moyens de
changer de véhicules voilà merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup Audrey pour
cette revue de presse régionale merci à
tous les deux d'avoir participé à ce
club lindalenay on va regarder la Une de
l'écho touristique qui est consacrée aux
enjeux de lit tourisme le tourisme sur
Internet c'est la fin de cette émission
on se retrouve demain dans bonjour chez
vous en recevra Gilles Boyer le député
européen son roman politique à suspense
écrit avec Édouard Philippe est adapté
en bande dessinée à 18h ce soir dans son
public vous retrouverez Thomas Hugues
merci de nous avoir suivis et très bonne
journée sur Public Sénat
[Musique]